♪ ♪
AMERICANS ARE STILL REELING FROM
COVID LOCKDOWNS --
THE COUNTRY'S BIGGEST TEACHERS
UNION WHICH PUSHED HER KIDS TO
BE REMOTE NOW HAS THE AUDACITY
TO BLAME THE MESS ON
REPUBLICANS.
SAYING THAT "CONSERVATIVES ARE
CONSISTENTLY WORKING TO
UNDERMINE LEADERS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THEY ARE IN THE SAME POINT THAT
WE ARE BETWEEN FEAR AND HOPE,
ASPIRATION AND THE FAIR,
DEMOCRACY AND HYPOCRISY.
THEY ARE DOING IT BECAUSE OUR
MEMBERS WORKED HARD DURING
COVID."
HERE'S WHAT ACTUALLY UNDERMINED
EDUCATORS: THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF COVID CASH THAT
SCHOOLS HAVE NOT USED.
SENATOR TIM SCOTT POINTING OUT
THIS "WALL STREET JOURNAL"
OP-ED, SAYING THAT THEY HAD ONLY
SPENT 7% OF $122 BILLION.
SENATOR, I WILL GO RIGHT TO YOU.
93% OF THAT MONEY IS WHERE?
>> SITTING THERE DOING NOTHING.
>> LET ME ASK YOU ONE MORE
QUESTION.
DO TEACHERS HAVE THE MONEY?
DO UNIONS HAVE THE MONEY?
>> SCHOOLS HAVE THE MONEY.
MY BILL TAKES THE MONEY FROM THE
SCHOOLS THAT ARE DOING NOTHING
AND PUTS IT IN THE HANDS OF
PARENTS.
IF WE ARE THE PARTY OF PARENTS,
WE HAVE THE PARTIES --
AND THE KIDS GET A BETTER
EDUCATION.
IF WE DON'T GET THAT RIGHT,
NOTHING ELSE WILL MATTER.
I CAN'T UNDERSTAND WHY THE
DEMOCRATS -- REFUSE EDUCATION,
NUMBER ONE, AND NUMBER TWO,
WHILE YOU HAVE 100 MILLION PLUS
DOLLARS SITTING ON YOUR BOOKS,
AND CANNOT USE IT --
FOR WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
PANDEMIC?
MORE CHARTER SCHOOLS.
THE POWER OF THE SYSTEM FOR ONE
PURPOSE: THE CHILD.
>> IT'S ALMOST LIKE A GRANT.
I HAD TO SPEND THAT MONEY, USE
IT.
WHY NOT HERE?
>> THE WAY THE MONEY CAME OUT,
IT WASN'T IN OUR HANDS.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THAT
IT'S ONE TIME MONEY.
WE SHOULD TAKE SOME OF THIS BACK
SINCE IT'S NOT BEING USED AND
REAPPROPRIATED FOR PARENTS.
THINK ABOUT IT, THE LEARNING
LOST OVER THOSE TWO YEARS COULD
COST OUR COUNTRY OVER
$2 TRILLION IN THE LIFETIME
EARNING OF OUR STUDENTS.
WE COULD ERASE MUCH OF THAT BY
SIMPLY PUTTING RESOURCES WHERE
THEY ARE NEEDED MOST.
>> SENATOR, WHY ARE YOUR SHOES
OFF?
>> YOU GUYS WERE SO GOOD IN THE
FIRST SEGMENT THAT I TOOK MY
SHOES OFF.
[LAUGHTER]
>> HE FEELS AT HOME.
GOOD FOR YOU, SENATOR.
>> I'M NOT WEARING SOCKS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> JUST DON'T TAKE ANYTHING ELSE
OFF, SENATOR.
GO TO GO VARGAS TEACHERS UNIONS
IN THE COUNTRY, THEY BOTH
RECEIVED A COPY OF --
IN PERSON LEARNING, THE CENTERS
FOR DISEASE CONTROL IS RELEASED
INTO THE PUBLIC.
DOESN'T THAT TELL YOU THAT THERE
IS A LITTLE BIT OF POLITICKING
BETWEEN THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
AND THESE UNIONS, WHICH MIGHT BE
A REASON WHY THEY GOT THE MONEY
AND HAVEN'T HAD TO SUBMIT IT?
>> MAYBE.
WHY WOULD YOU WANT TO EMPOWER
DOMESTIC TERRORISTS?
WE ARE BEING TOLD THAT'S WHAT
PARENTS ARE.
WHAT THEY WERE OBJECTING TO MOST
OF ALL WAS SCRUTINY, THE ABILITY
OF PARENTS TO LOOK CAREFULLY AT
THE PRODUCT THAT THEIR
CHILDREN -- THE UNION RESENTS
THAT.
IN A WAY, THE UNION IS LIKE A
BIG, FAT SEAL ON A POPULAR
TOURIST WORK.
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO GO GET ITS
FOOD ON ITS OWN: IT JUST --
PEOPLE JUST THROW IT FOOD.
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO WORK, BE
COMPETENT.
THAT'S THE UNION.
IT'S A BIG, FAT, FLABBY
DISGUSTING SEAL WHICH IS DOING
NOTHING TO HELP CHILDREN.
ONCE YOU SEE THAT, IT MEANS THAT
COMPETITION IS AROUND THE
CORNER.
THIS IS A GREAT LESSON FOR
LIBERALS, PROGRESSIVES,
DEMOCRATS.
IF YOU WANT SOMETHING GOOD, YOU
HAVE TO HAVE SOMETHING TO
COMPETE WITH IT.
AND THERE'S NO COMPETITION, YOU
END UP WITH AN AOC WHO, AS
NANCY PELOSI ONCE SAID -- "THAN
A CUP OF WATER."
YOU SUCK BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE
COMPETITION.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE FACT THAT THEY
CALLED PARENTS TO MYSTIC
TERRORISTS, PARENTS WHO CARED --
WHO CALLED THEM DOMESTIC
TERRORISTS?
>> IN A WAY, IT WAS A BLESSING
THAT WE STARTED TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT WAS GOING ON IN SCHOOLS.
>> I COULD NEVER FEED ANOTHER
SEAL FOR THE REST OF MY LIFE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> SENDING JESSE JR. TO PUBLIC
SCHOOL, HIS HOMEROOM TEACHER
TELLS HIM TO COME OUT OF THE
CLOSET, AND HIS HISTORY TEACHER
CALLS HIM A WHITE SUPREMACIST.
>> I WOULD BE JESSE SR. CALLING
THAT PARENT-TEACHER
CONFERENCE -- AND I WILL BE
BRINGING MAY BE YOU, MY LAWYER,
TO MAKE SURE THEY KNOW WHAT IS
APPROPRIATE AND ISN'T
APPROPRIATE TO TALK ABOUT WITH
MY FAMILIES.
WE ARE NOT UNDERMINING TEACHERS.
THEY ARE UNDERMINING MY FAMILY.
WORK HARDER THAN THE
FIREFIGHTERS.
ALL OF THOSE ESSENTIAL WORKERS
THAT HAD TO ACTUALLY SHOW UP TO
WORK EVERY DAY.
THEY ZOOMED IN FOR ALMOST TWO
YEARS.
THEY PROBABLY CALL IT WINTER
BREAK OR WINTER SOLSTICE INSTEAD
OF -- STOP ACTING LIKE THEY
WORKED THAT HARD.
THEN THEY HELD US HOSTAGE AND
BASICALLY SAID THEY WOULD WORK
UNTIL "YOU SEND US THE MONEY --"
THEY ALSO WANT A PARTICIPATION
TROPHY FOR NOT PARTICIPATING'S.
MOST WORKERS YOU JUDGE BY THEIR
WORK PRODUCTS, THEIR RESULTS.
IF YOU DO THAT, HAVE THEY
DELIVERED ANY GOOD RESULTS?
NO, TEST SCORES ARE GOING DOWN.
PERMISSION TO MAKE AN ANALOGY,
GREG?
THIS WOULD BE LIKE THE WORKERS
UNION WORKING EVERY OTHER DAY,
THEN PUTTING OUT CARS THAT DON'T
RUN AND BREAK.
THEY ARE MAKING BAD CARS!
THEY ARE SELLING US A LEMON AND
THEN CALLING US FASCISTS.
>> WHY IS IT THAT SCHOOLS NOW
ARE SHORT-STAFFED?
CAN TEACHER INCLUDES "WE ARE NOT
YOUR BABYSITTERS."
>> I DON'T MALIGN ALL POLICE
OFFICERS BECAUSE SOME DO NOT DO
THEIR JOBS.
POLICE OFFICERS ARE AMONG THE
MOST HONORED PUBLIC SERVANTS IN
THE LAND.
THERE ARE TEACHERS WHO DO GREAT
WORK.
TEACHERS IN A CERTAIN SCHOOL
DISTRICT, I WON'T MENTIONED
IT --
THEY LATER LEARNED THAT MANY OF
THE KID'S PARENTS ARE UNABLE TO
WASH THEIR CLOTHES OVER THE
WEEKEND, EMBARRASSED.
THEY DECIDE TO -- MORE WASHING
MACHINES THAN DRYERS.
I DON'T AGREE WITH AOC ON CRIME,
BUT YOU TALK ABOUT SOME SOCIAL
ISSUES THE COMMUNITY IS FACING.
THIS IS ONE OF THEM.
THOSE WHO DON'T WANT TO TEACH
SHOULD LEAVE THE PROFESSION.
>> A LOT OF THESE TEACHERS DON'T
SUPPORT IT, THEY ARE FINDING
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES, THEY DON'T
WANT TO LEAVE THEIR SCHOOL
SYSTEMS.
I GAVE YOU